- On this episode I get
my first video question,
I talk to Mister Money,
and we talk hashtags.
(rhythmic hip-hop instrumental music)
Welcome to episode seven.
Fun fact on the number seven,
that is the number of my
starting quarterback, Geno Smith.
Which reminds me, just so everybody knows,
episode seven, I'm in a
very bad mood this morning.
You might have seen my
tweets over the weekend.
Dexter McDougle our third-round pick
is out for the year.
Dee Milliner, our starting, best corner,
Dexter's also a corner.
Dee Milliner is out for four
to five, maybe six weeks
with a high ankle sprain.
In our first six games we play five
of the seven best passing attacks,
with Revis, that traitor piece
of crap going to New England.
We're depleted back there,
and I'm just generally sad.
Before we go into the questions this week,
I've been getting some emails of people
who are looking to get questions answered
that are a little more personal.
So, I've decided to go innovation-style,
I don't know if you can
zoom in here, DRock,
but right to the Cyber Dust.
I'm going to answer some
private questions tomorrow,
which is Tuesday, August 12,
'cause I know people
watch this all the time,
on Cyber Dust, user name Gary V-E-E.
Hit me up with your
questions that are personal
because on Cyber Dust, Mark
Cuban's kind of new venture,
big shout out to him.
The questions disappear,
they don't store anything,
they're playing up that privacy.
Some of you are lookin' to ask
some very personal questions,
so tomorrow I'm doing a lot of
driving around in New Jersey
from meeting to meeting,
and I will be answering private
questions tomorrow morning
on the dust, as I like to call it.
Garyvee, I'll see you tomorrow.
- [Voiceover] Mark asks, who are the idols
or the people that inspire you?
Did you ever have a mentor?
- Mark, you know, for people that watch me
or have followed me over the
last seven or eight years,
this is a very easy answer.
I've been hard-core about this.
I've never really been a big
fan of any business idols,
including the before-mentioned Mark Cuban,
or you know, really the two entrepreneurs,
or people that have ever
kind of over-indexed to me
were Walt Disney and Vince McMahon,
because they were heavy storytellers
and turned businesses out of that.
I like that, but to say
they were my mentors
or I looked up to them,
there is no Steve Jobs
or Donalds Trumps, or Carnegies,
there is nothing like that in my life.
My life is really focused
on two individuals:
Tamara and Sasha Vaynerchuk.
Tamara from the HR
people skill foundation,
Sasha from the work ethic, (spits in hand)
you know, we mentioned that
in episode three or four.
So, you know, they're
really my only mentors,
that's it.
- Hey Gary, my name's Matt,
and I'm a content creator
who makes his living off of YouTube.
Lately a lot of people have been asking me
what my next step is, because
they don't think YouTube
will last forever.
But I think it will only continue to grow.
So my question for you
is, should I hedge my risk
by expanding to other platforms,
or should I go all-in on YouTube.
I'd love to know what you think.
- Matt, how many of these people
have two million plus
subscribers on YouTube?
(bell ringing)
Thought so.
So go with your gut,
you were 100% correct.
I've already made a mistake
on YouTube early in my career
going to Viddler full-time.
And I made one right
correction of jumping on it
months after it came
out in the first place.
YouTube is the platform,
along with Netflix,
and emerging other platforms like a Vimeo
or an Amazon, Hulu,
many other things that
will pop up along the way.
YouTube is an anchor of
video content consumption,
and I think your
intuition is 100% correct,
and I would keep doing
exactly what you're doing.
I see it going nowhere, fast.
- [Voiceover] Mister Money asks,
what do you consider more valuable,
enthusiasm or action?
- Mister Money, before
I answer your question,
let me ask you a question.
How does one get a name like Mister Money?
That feels, pretty remarkable.
You know, Gary, Money.
(cash register ringing)
I like it.
Anyway, action or enthusiasm?
The truth is, my friend,
M squared, can I call you that?
Mister Money.
The real answer to that question, really,
is both.
The funny thing is, I know tons of people
with massive enthusiasm,
and they can't execute dick.
On the flip side, I know
people that can execute
A's on all their papers,
but without that passion,
or bravado, or fire,
they're only able to get limited return
on that investment of execution.
So to me, I'm probably a 60/40,
action execution 60, enthusiasm 40.
I know a lot of people might not get that,
but the truth is, I'm way more
proud of my execution skills,
all this charisma
hides what I really am, which
is a hard-core executer.
Don't forget, I had
executed a large business
before I ever hit the scene.
I was already 30 years old
when I started Wine Library TV.
And started that whole process and so,
I'm a 60/40 execution, enthusiasm action,
I might even be a 65/35.
Heck, as I sit here, maybe I'm a 70/30.
- [Voiceover] T.Jay asks,
how would you suggest
an indie artist use their marketing money
when the royalty check
comes in six months later?
- Jay, first of all,
thank you for the music,
today. Big ups to him.
And, the royalty check
coming six months later,
how do I think you should execute on that,
is very simple.
I think you should execute
six months of patience.
If you don't have the money,
you just wait for it to
come, and then you execute.
There is a lack, word play Jay,
and everybody else is watching.
There is a lack of patience.
The thought that your royalty
check comes six months later,
means that whatever you
wanted to do with that monies,
you know, to attack, just
has to wait six months.
And so, practically, I'd just wait.
- [Voiceover] Thomas asks, cake or pie?
- Thomas, this is quite simple.
For me, this is pie.
I'm obsessed with blueberry and apple pie,
though I don't eat those
kind of things anymore,
but, pie.
- [Voiceover] Liz asks,
any tips on how to make
an unknown hashtag, like #mommyenergy,
popular and well-known?
- Liz, first of all I love that name,
wife's name, sister's name.
Second of all, it makes me sad, Liz,
that I have to attack you, in a good way.
With the following question,
so everybody pour yourself
a little bit of sherry.
Grab your cigars if you
like that kind of thing.
'Cause this is a long-winded answer.
One of the things I thought
about over the weekend
is to give some real meat on the bones
on some of these answers.
You're gonna have your
pie or cake questions,
which I love by the way,
and I want more of those, by the way,
so ding those up.
Ding those up?
What the hell does that mean?
I also want to give long-winded answers
to when they deserve them, and Liz,
I appreciate you, because
you asked a question
that a lot of people are focusing on,
and I want to put some
real girth behind it.
And so here we go.
Liz, first question back to you,
a little ping pong action here is,
why do you want it to trend?
So you get something to trend,
and the interesting thing is,
as we all know, trending hashtags,
hashtags in general, are
actually not very own-able.
Right? If you create a hashtag,
anybody in the Twitter universe
can jump along and use that hashtag.
More importantly, when
hashtags, you know, trend,
we've seen a lot of spam people jump in
and use that hashtag in their tweet,
to create spam, to create porn.
You know, the funny thing is,
is I always ask why.
So my question to you is why?
Steve throw it out here, you
can be part of this question,
what's the hashtag?
- #mommyenergy.
- You know, by the way,
speaking of mommy energy,
I spoke with Steve's mom
on Twitter this weekend,
and she mentioned that
she liked Steve on camera,
so that was a little mommy energy.
You know, Liz, the real question is,
why would you want mommy energy to trend?
Do you feel that you then benefit from it?
Do you not realize that
every mommy blogger,
anybody selling products to mommies,
anybody authoring mommy books can jump in,
use that hashtag, there is no ownership.
There's limited upside.
You know, the only reason I
use the #AskGaryVee hashtag
is to find the questions easier.
It's a utility, it is
not a marketing engine,
to take me to the next level,
because I know it's so un-own-able.
And so, that is really
the question, to me,
to everyone who's watching, which is,
why would you want to own
it in the first place?
That's something that
you need to think about.
The why, against any
action, is really the thing
that people are not
spending enough time on.
The strategy matters.
My friends, I really
appreciate you being a part
of episode seven.
This show is taking off, as
many of you who've watched
all other six episodes know.
I'm leaving for family
vacation on Saturday,
we'll be out the pocket for two weeks.
So, there'll be a little hiatus as we go
right into football
season, which excites me.
I want to definitely ask you
for a strong favor,
which is to subscribe up.
("Hallelujah Chorus")
And I also wanna leave
with a new tradition,
which, for all you hard-core
Vaniacs, is an old tradition.
Many of you who watched
my thousand and 80 plus
wine shows, 1000 with Wine Library TV,
80 with Daily Grape, know that
I used to end every episode
with a question of the day.
Kind of ironic given the
format we roll with here.
But I'm gonna start asking
you a question of the day,
because I really like what's going on
in the YouTube comments.
One of the great things for me, pride,
is that I created an enormous
amount of friendships
in the wine world, because
people became friends
in the comment section.
I'm looking to do that again.
And so thus, by forcing
a question of the day,
more interaction there,
people jump into everybody's answers,
and it becomes one nice,
(hand clap) geshpuk.
And so, the question I have for you today,
first one ever, on the
#AskGaryVee show is,
which other personality
in the video world,
are you enjoying consuming content from?
Give him some love, give her some love.
It'll make me feel good.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep trying to answer them.
(rhythmic hip-hop instrumental music)
So ding those up.
Ding those up?
What the hell does that mean?
Ding as in, like tweet it out.
But, (laughs) ding!